[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: So
joining us today,
we've got-- in the middle
here, Rosie Spaulding,
the general manager of this
year's Rugby World Cup Sevens.
Rosie has spent her
career executing
many high-profile
sporting events, including
Super Bowl 50 here
in California,
and the 34th America's
Cup, which for those
of you not familiar is sailing.
I don't know if we talk too much
about that one in New Zealand
anymore--
among others.
Originally hailing
from the UK, Rosie
was previously the
events and marketing lead
for the Weymouth and Portland
National Sailing Academy,
where she helped develop that
center into a world class
venue that would later host
the London 2012 Olympic sailing
events.
So welcome, Rosie.
On the end of our
panel here, we've
got Ross Young, the
CEO of USA Rugby,
and Ross comes to USA
Rugby with over 20 years
of experience in
international rugby,
notably as the former general
manager to Rugby World Cup
Limited.
Ross is also from the UK, and
was previously a police officer
for the metropolitan services--
police service in Twickenham.
He moved to the US in 2013
when he joined "Ad-vaht-iss,"
is that--
ROSS YOUNG: Atavus.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Atavus,
in Seattle as the CEO,
and is transitioning to being
the permanent CEO of USA Rugby.
Has that come through?
When is that official?
ROSS YOUNG: It's near enough.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Near enough.
ROSS YOUNG: So I'm
currently the CEO
of USA Rugby and
the interim CEO.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Got it.
ROSS YOUNG: The Atavus
folks, all of the experience
was great for the
last five years.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Excellent.
And last but not least,
we've got Blaine Scully who's
captain of the USA men's
team, and is a local
born in Sacramento, California,
didn't begin playing rugby
until college, but took over
the game pretty quickly.
At Berkeley-- obviously just
over the bridge --earned
the titles of
four-time All-American,
captain of 2011 USA Rugby
Collegiate All-Americans
Touring Squad--
quite a mouthful --and
two national titles
with UC Berkeley.
Formerly a member of the
Lester Tigers, is it?
BLAINE SCULLY:
Lester Tigers, yeah.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Lester Tigers.
Now the captain of the US men's
national team, and the Cardiff
Blues, the chair of the US
Rugby Players Association,
which is an important role
that we'll probably get into.
So please give a round of
applause to all of our guests.
[APPLAUSE]
For all the panelists--
rugby has been gaining
popularity here in the US.
How did you get your
start in the game,
and what do you love about it?
So maybe starting
here with Blaine.
BLAINE SCULLY: I'm Blaine.
I started rugby when I was 18.
I was introduced to a friend.
But prior to that, I went
to Jesuit High School,
and Jesuit is one of the
perennial high schools
in the country, won numerous
national championships,
and a lot of my buddies played
on national championships
with Jesuit.
And I went to UCLA first
before I went to Cal.
I was introduced to
rugby by a friend there,
and it was what I was supposed
to be playing all along.
I was kind of an
athlete without a sport.
My dad and brother
played college football,
uncles played baseball, and
I was supposed play rugby.
And the thing I love
most about the game is it
challenges you in so many
different athletic ways.
Everyone's got to be able to
pass, catch, tackle, jump,
a multitude of skills, so that
challenges all different types
of athletic abilities.
And then at the same time,
it's very much a players' game.
Players are tasked
with decision-making,
connecting with teammates, and
it's quite different than NFL,
for instance, where a coach
can very much direct the game.
After Friday, and as you
get into the competition,
it's very much team-oriented.
And so it's all about the
team, and making decisions
on the game.
So I find it really one of
the best there is out there.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's great.
And we're going to jump
into your role as captain,
and what that really
means, a little bit later
in the discussion.
Rosie, how did you get involved?
ROSIE SPAULDING: Yeah, so
my introduction to rugby
is a fan, basically.
So I grew up in the
UK, and following
a small but noisy
and very enthusiastic
team called the Cornish Pirates.
And just following
rugby with my family,
and going to games a number of
times, for those [INAUDIBLE]..
And just really
enjoying the sport.
And then when I transitioned
into sports event production
eighteen years ago, planned
an produced a number of events
around the globe, but this is
the first rugby tournament I've
been involved in
planning and producing.
And very excited to be doing
that, and to have this role,
and to be hopefully
creating a platform--
continued platform for growth
of the game here in the US.
So very excited
about the tournament
that's around the corner.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's awesome.
Ross.
ROSS YOUNG: Yeah,
similar to Rosie,
being from the UK, involved
literally from school.
Then decided to join the
Metro Police in London.
At that stage, prior to the
game being professional,
you couldn't earn
money playing rugby.
So the Armed Forces,
police services
were good ways to actually
play at the highest level
and have time
facilitated to play.
And at that stage,
the team I played
for had multiple England
internationals playing
for it as well.
But so, certainly never a
regular first team player.
Usually the one that
filled the back of the bus
when the prima
donnas didn't want
to take the trip to
the Cornish Pirates
or up to North Yorkshire after
a night duty on a Saturday.
[LAUGHTER]
But just loved the camaraderie,
as you say, and then, you know,
the transition really happened--
I had a couple of
very bad knee injuries
when I was relatively
young, and decided
I was going to break into
the world of coaching,
and dominate that
way, and then realized
I was terrible at that.
So I gave up.
You know, I think coaching you
have to have a certain mindset,
and unfortunately
for a player that
was criticized for not being
angry and aggressive enough,
I was far too aggressive
and angry as a coach.
So I got involved
in administrations,
and then just built
up connectivity
through the rugby network
from a policing perspective,
and policing at Twickenham,
and then was lucky enough
to get involved with
Harlequins in the early stage
of professionalism as
their stadium manager,
and eventually general
manager, before moving on
to World Rugby.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's great.
And I noticed some kind
of common uncommon theme
maybe here.
You know, Blaine, you
said you didn't really
get into rugby
until you were 18,
whereas Rosie and
Ross grew up with it.
So we do think the
kind of turning point
for rugby in the US
is, and how can we
get more kids involved in a way
that in New Zealand, Australia,
the UK, or South Africa,
they are just naturally
from the beginning.
BLAINE SCULLY: I mean,
I think you're already
seeing it starting.
Obviously, the
Olympic movement's
been really big for us.
I think it's validated rugby
in this country in a way
it hadn't been
probably previously.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY:
And can you explain
to the folks who might not
know what that looks like.
BLAINE SCULLY: So rugby was
included in the 2016 Olympic
Games, and will be for the next
two Olympic Games, I believe,
as well.
So obviously, as
a young athlete,
there's a couple
things you aspire to,
and being an Olympian
is one of them.
And in sevens format
being what it is,
I think it lends itself really
well to introducing the game.
It's high-energy, high-pace,
which we'll see this weekend,
and really kind of a
pure athletic version
of rugby, which I think is
really suited for Americans
in general.
And obviously,
hopefully we can build
from the ground up introducing
meaningful competition
for young athletes
at a young level,
making sure they get
adequate coaching,
and building enthusiasm,
exposure for the sport.
So I mean, an event
like we're having
this weekend is
massive in the sense
that it gives a young athlete
an aspiration they can actually
see, and touch, and feel,
which is hugely important.
It's not just about going
to an NFL game, or even
a college football game.
It's being able to see
world class athletes play
a game at its highest
level, and that's
something that's truly
powerful for a young athlete.
ROSIE SPAULDING: And
just to add to that,
the Olympics was huge,
for sure, and then
also rugby is currently
the fastest-growing team
sport on college campuses,
so there's definitely
a change happening.
And I think for my
part, how do we never
sees your World Cup-class
competitions to really grow
the game in our way.
And for sure, you're
exactly right,
being able to see world class
athletes, men and women, which
is, again, quite unique about
rugby and one of the things
I love about it, to have those
two men's and women's World
Cups running
alongside each other
is a great inspiration
for the kids
out there just getting into
the game, but also making sure
that we implement
a legacy program,
and we've be working on
the Impact Beyond program
here in the Bay Area
through this tournament.
So just the exposure is
one of the key pieces
from my side in the US, because
we are growing the game.
It is an emerging sport.
But by exposing kids--
we've exposed 22,000 kids to
rugby, given them the chance
to participate through
our Impact Beyond program
through this event.
And so those kind of programs,
I think, can only help.
And hopefully the awareness is
grown through this tournament,
and then the participation
is also growing
through this tournament.
ROSS YOUNG: And from a national
governing body perspective
it's a balancing
act, as Blaine said--
having an aspirational
team, raising the profile,
having more rugby on TV.
In the five years I've been
here it's been a huge learning
curve, and I think
that everyone that's
got interest in rugby out there
will realize, instead of--
I think it was mentioned--
Josh, earlier-- instead of
hooking into something dodgy
VPN connection five years
ago to find rugby content,
and it's now on--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: I
have never done that.
ROSS YOUNG: No, nobody's
ever done that, have they?
You know, now that
ESPN has basically
got most of the
southern hemisphere
and the French NBC have got
the northern hemisphere--
the English Premiership and the
Six Nations, moving forward.
And then with the advent of
MLR in the US, which I think
is going to be a great
springboard for us
to build off, being on
CBS and the ESPN platform,
as well as local cable networks.
There's a lot more
there, and so it's really
harnessing the
aspirational qualities,
and then building
from the base up.
And it's easier said than done.
I mean, Rosie
mentioned the SFIA--
Sports Fitness and
Industry Association
of the US, rugby for
the last three years
has been the biggest
incremental sport.
It's still small in
comparison numbers,
but it's sort of
jumped above lacrosse,
and they take playing all
forms of the game in interest
rather than just
pure registration.
So we need to keep
building on that.
But like everything, you
need to have outlets,
and you need to have clubs
built for players to play.
I think the-- in
my previous job,
we were very much youth-focused,
with running camps and player
development programs.
And the amount of
times we'd go to areas,
and people would get
hooked, but then they've
got no club or
association to play with.
So the younger the
kids are playing,
then the more you care, and
then I think as Blaine said,
the Jesuit High School
here in the Bay Area
has a long history, but there
weren't very many high schools.
Now there's a lot more.
There's a lot more
college scholarships
available for high school kids.
So we just keep on pushing
away at all levels,
really, and making sure that
we get the balance right.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: And
one of the things
you touched on
about the TV rights.
And I think that is an important
source of income for the game.
There's only so much that
each individual subscription
can kind of get you.
So maybe sticking
with you, Ross,
can you talk a little
bit about how rugby
has to compete with the other
sports for sponsorship dollars,
and particularly in a game
where it's free-flowing,
in the 15s at least.
It's slightly less
so in the sevens.
Whereas in baseball,
basketball, football,
there are lots of
breaks for advertising.
ROSS YOUNG: I think revenue
generation is important,
and also access
to terrestrial TV,
and NBC has historically
been a great partner,
and just entered into
a long-term partnership
with World Rugby that really
allows some of that leverage.
Because as you say, when
you are selling sponsorship,
it needs to be on
the right platform
with the most eyes on it.
But you also need be
creative with sponsorship.
I mean, rugby just doesn't
hit the same criteria.
So when we're doing pitching
to sponsors and partners,
they tend to have
media agencies that
have algorithms that
work through, well, you
need x number of
people, x eyes on it,
and that equates a value.
So I think we've got
to turn that, instead
of it being the financial
value, we've got
some great new partners that--
get them to embrace
the values of rugby,
get them to understand where
we are in the growth path,
and be part of that
journey with us,
and really align what we're
doing as an organization
through to a lot of their
strategic goals as a company,
and help build that value.
And then hopefully
the dollars will come,
but it's always been a
struggle for rugby, through--
even through the established
nations competing
with the big numbers in Europe.
But we'll get there.
We've just got to keep on--
make a proper plan,
stick with it,
and hopefully it will
come to fruition.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Rosie,
coming back down this way,
down the panel,
you've been involved
in a number of high-profile
sporting events in the US,
as we mentioned in
the introductions,
including the Super Bowl and
the America's Cup sailing.
What is different about the
sevens from your perspective?
ROSIE SPAULDING: A couple of
key differences, I would say.
I think one of the exciting
pieces for me personally,
but also a challenging
component is the way
that it is an emerging sport.
So while we've been promoting
and marketing the tournament
for the past 18 months, it's--
and in parallel with
doing that, we're
actually having to explain what
rugby is, and explain the game,
and there's this whole
education component that
comes alongside that,
until right now,
actually, where we're
very much an awareness--
I guess awareness generating
as well as the planning piece,
which we haven't had
to worry about so much
with the Super Bowl--
America's Cup to some extent.
I think there's some
similarities with the America's
Cup in that we're trying
to grow the audience.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Yeah,
I'm not sure how many
young American children
aspire to be elite sailors.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROSIE SPAULDING: You never know.
But in terms of growing the
fan base and that side of it,
it was somewhat similar.
And then I think
the other difference
for me is just that it's
an incredible sport,
and just the values
really resonated,
the sort of teamwork, respect,
and inclusivity around rugby
is very much, I think,
authentic throughout the game,
throughout wherever
it's played, and I
think that's something
that stands out compared
to some of the other sports.
And then I guess
probably a third thing
I'll add in there is
the fan experience.
And for sevens, at
least anyway, people
come as much to watch the
Olympic class athletes-- world
class athletes --as they
do to be entertained.
And it's a really fun
event to entertain people
as well as just the
sport side of it.
It's a great sort
of beta breakers--
we sort of joke about
it being beta breakers
meets rugby meets
Olympic athletes,
and that resonates with
folks here in the Bay Area.
And that's different.
I think that's
special to sevens.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's great.
I'm picking up on that theme.
Blaine, you mentioned
earlier the decision-making
that the players have on the
field, and the kind of passing
of the baton from the
coach over to the players,
particularly the
captain in your case.
Talk to us a little bit
about what that means,
both in the sevens and
15s form of the game,
and how you handle that from
a leadership perspective.
BLAINE SCULLY:
Yeah, I'd say it's
very much a service-based
responsibility position.
You serve the team, and you're
responsible for the team,
and speaking with
the team's voice,
and representing the team,
whether it's conversations
with the referee, or
the press, and even
inside a team dynamic, between
the coaches and the playing
group, and between the
playing group and the coaches.
So very much serve all
the different entities,
and then my mindset's
always been you're very much
a first among equals.
It's not a privileged position.
It's a service position.
And I think that's one of the
really unique aspects about
rugby is that it is very much
everything about the 15 people
that are on the field, or the
seven people on the field,
and supporting one another,
because really that's
all you have.
There's limited substitutions
in both forms of the games.
So you have to problem
solve and come up
with solutions on the
field because there's only
two breaks, halftime
and the end of the game.
You really don't get any other
chances besides that in order
to download
information, communicate
between your teammates, and try
to figure out how the heck are
we going to win this game.
And obviously a lot of that
is down to how you prepare,
and getting ready
for competition.
And then once the
pressure's there and once
the balls are
live, then how well
do you react and respond to
all the different elements
and various things
that can derail a team,
and disrupt connection
and decision-making,
and it really has to be one
collective unit on the plan,
and executing it to the best of
their ability for 80 minutes.
So it requires a huge amount
of preparation, obviously,
and training.
Your ability to decision-make
and connect on the field.
And then you have
to be fit enough
to be able to do it for
however long it takes.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: And do the fans
getting too loud ever impact
on your on-field communication,
particularly the sevens?
BLAINE SCULLY: It
definitely can be a factor.
I think probably more so
in sevens it's your lungs.
It is very, very
fast-paced game,
and it is happening quick.
So you only have
really micro-seconds
to connect and have
a conversation.
So that's why communication
for us is so important,
is you have to be
able to give it
and give it back really quickly.
So being able to
communicate on the field
when you don't have
a lot of breaks
is a hugely important
part of really a team
functioning, as anybody knows
in any team in the world.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Yeah,
definitely correct,
and I think the way teams
function here at Google as well
is that kind of trust
and communication,
and you can't always
have the person there.
You've got to figure it
out a lot on your own.
BLAINE SCULLY: It
would be nice if I
was at the wing to send a
text message to my scrum,
how's it going?
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Exactly.
With the wearables
team, I can probably
get in touch about that.
Ross, going back to
you, but sticking
on the path of
elite athletes, how
do you identify, and train,
and kind of bring people
into the USA Rugby program?
Because I imagine you want to
be identifying folks early,
and taking them all the
way through to these kind
of aspirational paths that
Blaine was mentioning.
ROSS YOUNG: Yeah, we touched
on that a little bit,
and Blaine obviously
represented the All-Americans
at various different
age groups, and there's
a good history of age group
representation with the US.
But there are challenges.
I mean, the geography
of the country--
I mean, the hotbeds tend to
be around the bigger populated
areas, around the east
coast, west coast,
and I think Texas has always
had a long history as well.
So its volunteers-- it's
network of volunteers,
its ensuring that regionalized
rugby organizations are
equipped to be able
to push forward
certain recommendations.
There's a number of
entities out there
that run camps that the
upscale-- certain players.
And I think through the
state-based organizations,
through the volunteer
network, it's
just pushing people in
the bottom of the funnel,
and allowing them to then
to then be challenged.
A lot the other
issues of that come
back to having the finances
and resources able to do that.
If you want the best group
of players in an age group
to get together, it's got to
be in one area of the country,
obviously.
And there's a lot of them
got to fly a long way
and stay to do it.
So it's never easy.
The advent-- technology's,
again, another great help.
More and more games
are being filmed.
More and more games are being
broken down and reviewed.
So getting that film out
there as well is important.
But for us it's having
the right coaches
in place at the right
age grade levels that
have the connectivity
through the various parts
of the country that can go out
there and identify the talent.
And people keep on
talking about it,
and there's some great examples
in the sevens game as well
of the crossover athlete, and
players that maybe haven't
quite made it to
the NFL or the NBA,
and Blaine will probably
talk more to that.
It's interesting that
football is obviously
seen as a farm for
building athletes,
but a lot of what
happens in basketball
has probably got more
synergy to the game of rugby,
and use of space, et cetera.
So I think having the
ability to supplement teams
with incredible athletes that
are part of the American system
is great, but it comes back
to what we talked about
earlier, that it's
a complex game,
and the younger you
play it, the better.
And I think for all
of us here there's
a huge advantage
that rugby is now
being seen as being an outlet.
A lot of football coaches
are encouraging their players
to play rugby, whereas
previously they were restricted
from doing that, because
of the complementary skills
in both sports.
So it's age-- as young as
possible, and then by all
means try and get
the athlete along
to supplement the
skill base later on.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Rosie, I want
to get your views on what you've
been doing around
this tournament
to increase what Ross has been
saying, which is viewership,
and getting people involved who
may not really know the game,
and have that passion for it.
Can you talk to us
a little about some
of the programs that kind
of dovetail with what
Ross has been talking about on
the players' side for the fans?
ROSIE SPAULDING:
Yeah, and I think
it's been our approach--
sort of marketing-wise--
has been very much sort of
tapping into other audiences.
We know that the rugby fan
base are probably pretty
excited about this tournament.
So it's as much about making
them aware of the tournament,
but they're more easily sold.
And what we've been
working on is other ways
to relate the game to football,
and encourage football fans
to get excited about it, or
because it's at AT&T Park,
through the Giants fan base.
But also a big
piece is what it was
talking about before, which
is the entertainment side,
and just tapping
into what is a--
I think there's a
lot of synergies
between the sevens fan and the
population of the Bay Area--
not everybody, but
generally the sort
of celebration part of sevens,
and the costumes that people
tend to wear, the fancy dress
that people wear for sevens,
and the fun that people
have at sevens very much
resonates with
the Bay Area here.
So we've very much been focused
on that, and the fun side,
and the entertainment
piece, and pulling that
into our marketing and promotion
over the past year or so.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: I was in Vegas
a few years ago for the sevens,
and made the front
page of the BBC News.
It said, "American fans
enjoying themselves in Vegas."
I was in a penguin costume.
I'm not entirely
sure what country
they thought I was from.
But I was with a lot
of my American friends
who were very clearly
supporting America.
So talking about the
sevens and the 15s form
of the game, Blaine, how
does your training change
depending on--
you mentioned the kind
of lung capacity required
for the sevens, and the form
of the game is quite different.
Talk to us a little bit about
how that changes what you do.
BLAINE SCULLY: Yeah,
so I mean obviously,
from a sevens
perspective, you play
multiple games in a weekend.
So your anabolic threshold
and your aerobic capacity
needs to be very, very high
from an athletic point of view.
That means you have
to be able to be
prepared to sprint a lot of
times in a short amount of--
a short period of time as well.
So it's a tough
training regimen.
A lot of running, and you
have to actually be very, very
efficient in what
you do as an athlete,
because the game of sevens is
very isolating for an athlete
because there's only
seven people on the field.
Every once in a while you
can kind of potentially
hide on a 15s field.
There is zero hiding
on a sevens field.
Typically, the
classic example is
you hide a front rower because
you need him for scrum time,
right.
Sevens, there's no hiding.
Everyone's got to be able to
do everything at all times,
and do it at a high, high
intensity for 14 minutes,
whereas in 15s it's very much
a bigger man's game, more set
piece, which is just-- for
anyone out there-- is just
a way to restart play.
There's a couple
of ways to do that.
There's a line out, which is
sort of like a jump ball soccer
throw-in, and then a scrum
is kind of a classic example
as well.
And very much a position
is dictated by the demands
of whatever that is.
So a front rower's
specific job is to scrum,
just like an offensive liner
would be tasked to block.
But he also has to be
able to pass, and tackle,
and all that kind
of stuff as well.
And 80 minutes is
challenging because it's
a lot of intensity, so
kind of break it down.
I'd typically run seven
and a half kilometers
a game, probably
more, in addition
to having 20, 30 collisions.
So our training regimen
will try to reflect what
we are faced with in the game.
So we want to train
above the game,
so that means we're
running high intensity,
and our meters have to be
at a certain percentage
of high speed.
And then the way we train
our contacts, I have to be--
my teammates and I have to meet
a certain amount of contacts
per training session
in order to make
sure we're physically prepared
for when we play the game.
So our trainings are
very much reflective
of what the game demands.
And really, they're-- while
they're both forms of rugby,
they are slightly
different in that way.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: So you
touched on two things
that I want to pick
up on, one for you,
and then flicking
it back to Ross.
But for you, Blaine,
trying to explain
to the American audience,
or people who haven't seen
rugby before, the concept
of a scrum or a line out.
Rosie and I know what that means
because we grew up with it.
How do you find explaining,
even to your friends and family
when you first started
out, what you were doing,
and how do we get a
common language for people
to understand this?
BLAINE SCULLY: Yeah, well, I
mean, just from my experience,
so I mean, I was
introduced to rugby,
and I was new to the sport once.
You know, so what
I did is I just
took the basic
elements of the game,
and I tried to break it down and
put in the stuff that I know.
I know what a kick
return is like when
a returner returns a football.
And so there's a lot
of that in rugby.
Like I said, a line out
is sort of like a jump
ball meets a soccer throw-in
that has to go the middle.
I can kind of picture of what
that is, and kind of see--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY:
Lots of analogies
back with the American sports.
BLAINE SCULLY: A scrum is
effectively two offensive lines
going head to head, and they
put the ball down the middle,
and then it's a contest.
Everything in rugby is
very contest-driven,
even in-- like take the
tackle for instance.
In football, play stops, whereas
in rugby it's another contest.
So a new line of
scrimmage is established,
which football fans would
know, but then the offense
and defense are still
trying to get that ball.
So I just equated
stuff I knew, and then
thankfully for YouTube, I was
able to watch a lot of rugby.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Great.
YouTube shout-out there.
And touching, then, on
some of the safety aspects.
You know, Ross, it's
probably a question for you,
as well as interested in
thoughts from Rosie and Blaine.
But what are you
doing for USA Rugby
to encourage parents
of young children
that this is a
safe game to play,
and the way that you treat
tackling and other hit
injuries.
Talk to us a little
bit about that,
especially given the
spotlight on American football
in that regard.
ROSS YOUNG: Yeah, and I think
there are lots of quotes
out there about saying the head
injuries that have received
a huge amount of
publicity in football
is an advantage for rugby.
I mean, I disagree with that.
It's still a high-impact sport.
Being involved in
an environment--
Blaine says that it has
many collisions, that it's
all about force and power.
I think the big
advantage that rugby has,
and the one thing we have
to continue to focus on
as a national governing body
is the quality of coaching,
because that--
ultimately technique
is what helps you
in rugby when it comes to
those impact situations.
And you know, the transference
in my previous role
at [INAUDIBLE] Rugby
and then Atavus,
there's a whole other arm shoot
of the business that's gone
off, which is all about
designing a very specific
defensive system and tackle--
taking the complementary
parts from the rugby tackle
and moving it into a
football environment
from drills, et cetera.
Texas High School
Association has just
mandated that all
their youth coaches
have to take the
certification for that, which
is going to continue
to help and improve
from a rugby perspective.
So for us, it's those younger
kids at the younger ages,
as Rosie will attest to.
When you start off
playing mini rugby
in the southern hemisphere, one
of the very first things you
do--
it's very game-based,
it's fun-based.
But it's all about learning
to fall, learning how to roll,
learning to protect
yourself, and you
build the more complex
elements of the game
into that as you go forward.
And unfortunately--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Not
the Neymar roll there.
ROSS YOUNG: No, not
quite the Neymar roll.
BLAINE SCULLY: He was on
the ground for 15 minute,
I believe.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: 15 minutes?
ROSS YOUNG: It's a bit like
Blaine's version of that.
BLAINE SCULLY: Come on, man.
[LAUGHTER]
ROSS YOUNG: From our perspective
it is-- you have to--
coaching is so-- you know,
you said earlier about,
what do we have to do to
improve the numbers of players?
By the way, the Neymar was
more the pretty boy thing
rather than lying on the field.
[LAUGHTER]
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: I
reserve all my judgments.
ROSS YOUNG: No, it's coaching
and the number of coaches that
really understand what
to do, and the younger
you get kids playing, because
it's much tougher to do at,
I mean, when Blaine
started, his age.
It just doesn't
become instinctive,
and I think that's the
big difference is rugby,
the younger you start, the
more instinctive it becomes,
how you protect yourself going
into a tackle, and a tackle,
and I think there's
more technology around
that, you said there's
more game review that's
going to help that.
So doing that, and helping
that, and driving through,
especially, an awareness
in the US about it
is massively important.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY:
And Rosie, I'm not
sure if you are involved
in this as well,
but the publicity and the
marketing piece of it,
is much of that focused
on parents, saying hey,
bring your kids along?
ROSIE SPAULDING: Yeah, for
the tournament, you mean?
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Yeah, for
the tournament, and then more
broadly.
ROSIE SPAULDING:
Yeah, absolutely.
That's part of
what we do, or part
of what I'm doing, is
the marketing promotion,
and very much certainly
to rugby fans,
very focused on the
parents as a core audience
across the country, but
also very much here, again,
in the Bay Area making sure
that rugby clubs are aware,
and that kids feel engaged.
And then like I talked about,
through the Impact Beyond
program, it's also
increasing that awareness,
and getting into the
82 schools that we've
got into that have not played
rugby before, and just growing
the game.
And we've had a really,
really, really positive
reception to rugby, and we've
been in schools where they
really had no idea what it was.
But the fact that boys and
girls can play it, the fact that
the values, the thinking--
I've mentioned them
previously but the core values
of teamwork, and
respect, and inclusivity
are very authentic
and very genuine,
I think, in rugby, and
something that aligns
very well with school programs.
And so it's been
very well-received,
and the parents have
been excited about it,
the kids have been
excited about it,
and it's another way that we've
been operating the tournament,
but also helping to
grow the game as well.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's great.
And you mentioned obviously
both boys and girls play.
I think this weekend is
a great example of that.
We've got a combined tournament
where the men and the women
are playing the tournament
at the same location, which
I'm really happy to say.
I think it helps with
promotion of the game,
particularly for women.
And Blaine, you're involved--
the chair of the
Players Association.
Does that-- is it
the same association
for the male players
and the female players?
And talk to us a bit
about how that's going,
and what your role is there.
BLAINE SCULLY: So we're
very fortunate to have
that up and running.
We've been working on it
for a couple of years.
So it's inclusive of all four
national teams, men and women,
and our board reflects that.
It's two representatives
from each team, so sevens
and 15s on both sides.
So it's four women and five--
only because myself as chair.
And it's something we're
really looking forward
to building, is kind of
that universal standard,
and standardizing expectations,
and from an athletes'
perspective, player welfare.
That's not gender
specific-- gender equal.
And that's really what we
think the game is about,
and we think we want to
be about as well, So being
really inclusive, and growing.
It's not enough just to grow
one aspect of the sport.
We want to raise,
collectively, all boats,
because I think, personally,
that the women's game has
a huge opportunity
in America to be--
I think it's-- well, it's
actually one of the only
contact options
women have to play.
And I think we have so
many world class female
athletes that can
bring us on a level
that we've already
demonstrated we're very, very
competitive on the world stage.
We were fourth at
last year's World Cup.
We won a bronze medal and
silver medal this year,
and I think it's really exciting
from a union's perspective
that our women have
so much potential,
and are already seeing success.
So I think it's the right
thing that we're all in this
together, and hopefully
we can do our part
to leave the jersey in the
better place, which is really
what we're all about from a
Players Association standpoint.
We want to leave it
better than we found it.
We want to be a part
of growing the game,
but we also want to grow the
people in the game, which
is really, really
important for us,
and that's not just male
or female, it's everyone.
ROSS YOUNG: From a national
governing body's perspective,
we've got to respect that.
I mean, we joked about
Neymar, and what was
it, 100 million euros a week.
I mean, there's a
financial responsibility.
The players, both the men
and women, are huge assets.
We talked about building value
through sponsor and sponsor
relations.
We need to use
them in a way that
builds out a collective
benefit that goes into a pot.
I mean, collective bargaining
agreements are pretty much
standard in the other
established rugby countries,
and we don't have that.
But if we are going to
benefit, then the players
need to benefit, and as a
national governing body,
we need to ensure that,
again, both the men
and women, that
they're a part of that,
are looked after properly,
these player welfare issues
that other players
unions have addressed
in other parts of the world.
And obviously, creating
a financial model,
because they just don't get
paid enough for what they do,
and is just ensuring that
we use that union as well
to create a pot that
helps renumerate them
for the time, and
effort, and dedication
that they've got to the sport.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Yeah,
totally agree and support,
and I think it's had to build
that up from the beginning.
And I think there's an innate--
in New Zealand and
some other countries,
there's just everyone wants
to play for the jersey,
and they'd really do it for
not a whole lot of money often.
So I think building
that up is so important,
having that be a goal for the
kids when they start playing.
So we have time for
audience questions.
Is there anything on
the Dory, [INAUDIBLE]??
Folks on Livestream,
definitely put your questions
into the Dory, but do we have
any questions in the room?
AUDIENCE: My nephew is 10,
just starting out the sport,
playing flag rugby,
getting involved.
I know Blaine, you mentioned
about looking stuff up
on YouTube--
the hard part about YouTube
is there are tons of videos,
and a lot of times you just
get the big hit videos.
What maybe recommendation
would you give to--
I mean, not only the youth,
but maybe some older players
who are looking to YouTube to
kind of learn about the sport--
maybe just some
direction on that.
BLAINE SCULLY: Yeah.
No, for sure.
I think it doesn't matter
if you're a 10-year-old,
or me, I'm a 30-year-old
now, curiosity
is fundamentally a huge part
of your growth as an athlete.
And so when I was first starting
out, I watched the game,
and obviously was learning
as much as I could.
And then I started specifically
picking out players
who I thought I would
want to play like,
and who my skill set paralleled.
And so what I would do is--
and I still actually do it
to this day, because
now, fortunately, I'm
part of a professional
setup, and we
have every game in
the world coded,
and I still go in
and watch Ben Smith,
who's a very good All Black.
I'll watch his clips,
because it's really important
to see what the best
players are doing,
because there's a reason why
they're the best players.
So I'd say for
any young athlete,
having that fundamental
curiosity is a huge component
to your growth as an athlete.
And then being able
to put in the work
to actually do the homework,
and then going out on the field
and actually working hard
to try to get better.
And that doesn't stop
whether you're 10 or an older
athlete like myself now.
AUDIENCE: One of the best things
about sevens is the atmosphere.
You alluded to it a few times.
I sit in GHS so I can
sit with the Nigerians
because they're singing
through the whole thing,
and it's a blast.
Who are you looking
forward to seeing play,
and maybe in your case,
Blaine, if you want to--
who do you like
playing against, or is
the team that drives
you nuts, like Fiji
or somebody, where it's just--
BLAINE SCULLY: Fiji
drives everybody nuts.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Exactly,
and that's the fun
part is each team
has a personality,
the fans bring the
personality to the game.
So just curious, as you look to
this weekend, who should we--
don't be in the parking lot when
they're playing, besides the US
team, of course.
ROSS YOUNG: Add something
then I'll pass on to Blaine,
but I think that that's the--
each team has its own character.
Each team has its own style.
The balance of pace and power.
I mean, the Fijians,
you said, are just so--
they've managed to put a bit
of structure behind the flair
that they used to have, which
has made them even stronger.
The issue of sevens
as well is anybody
can win on the day,
which is a great upside.
It's also one of
the risks around it.
The World Cup in Dubai,
the top four seeds
all went out in
the quarterfinals,
and you ended up with Kenya,
Wales, Argentina, and Samoa,
I think, in the semifinals.
BLAINE SCULLY: And Wales, won.
Yeah, 2009.
ROSS YOUNG: Wales
ended up winning.
And have never won
a tournament before,
and they've never won a
tournament since in sevens.
So there is an unpredictability.
And sevens is definitely
about the event, as well as
the sport that's taking place.
But you're right, there
are some incredible fans.
There's a great
culture to it, and I
think-- we keep on talking
about the brand values
as well as the camaraderie,
all the fans mingling together.
It just adds something
very special.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Do you
guys want to add on.
ROSIE SPAULDING:
I was just going
to add on that we're
fortunate that there's
28 countries competing this,
weekend, and all of them
are represented here in the Bay
Area, which is really exciting.
So from a fan perspective,
it's been one of our tracks
for marketing as well, has been
working through the communities
here in the Bay Area, the
Consul General in the Bay Area,
to attract all
those nationalities,
and I think we expect to
see a lot of national pride,
and a lot of excitement,
and all of those fans
coming out to watch.
So I think that's very unique
about sevens, and really unique
about this tournament, and it's
something to be excited about.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Blaine,
who do like playing,
and who drives you mad?
[LAUGHTER]
BLAINE SCULLY:
Obviously you mentioned
the Fijians are incredible
and unpredictable, but more
incredible than not.
I think the South Africans
have a really good chance
this weekend.
They're--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: He's
saying that to rile me up.
BLAINE SCULLY: No.
I mean, they're just such
a well-balanced team.
ROSS YOUNG: Well, they're
ranked number one.
BLAINE SCULLY: They're
such a well-balanced team,
they're well-coached,
and they have a lot
of really quality players.
I mean, you can go
across the board.
(FACETIOUSLY) New Zealand
is OK at rugby, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
They all have a chance--
ROSS YOUNG: If you
take the blinkers off
they'd be even better.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY:
Sometimes we like
to let the other
countries have it too.
BLAINE SCULLY: Yeah, but
they both just mentioned
that the thing with sevens is--
I mean, if you're the
better team for 14 minutes,
anything can happen.
And whether you're South
Africa or someone like Chile,
it doesn't matter.
The game of sevens is pure
and ruthless form of rugby
that there is, because
anything can happen.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: And just before
we got to the next audience
question, I know there have
been some big games, mainly
out in Chicago, on the 15s side.
We'll have another series
coming up on November 3rd,
I think it is, out
there this year.
Is that something that the more
mature rugby-playing nations
can really help the US grow
by doing these kinds of more
exhibition-type games?
Ross.
ROSS YOUNG: Yeah,
I mean the profile
of when the Eagles play the All
Blacks maybe four years ago now
in Soldier Field to a sell-out.
It was ridiculous.
The Ireland game
that New Zealand
played a couple of years
later, and then as you said,
we've got Ireland back
playing Italy this time,
plus the men's Eagles
playing the Mary 15,
and then the Black
Ferns playing the women
in that triple-header.
And I think the more that we
can do that to raise profile,
then the better it is.
But again, it's all
about a balancing act.
It's not overdoing it,
it's not saturating.
We need to support what
we're doing domestically
as well so that
people really get
behind what the national
team are doing rather
than concentrating on the
other teams that are out there,
and the big names
that are coming in.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Fair enough.
I think I've got
another question.
AUDIENCE: From a-- there's
a number of different entry
points into rugby as a sport,
as you guys have spoken about.
But in the southern hemisphere
and in Europe that's--
the primary drive of that
is through the club system,
which potentially
we don't really have
the same format here in the US.
Sports are generally driven
through a collegiate point
of view.
First of all, I'd be
interested to hear,
is that where you think
you need to double down on?
IS it from a collegiate
point of view,
and to drive player
participation through that?
And then secondly,
more for Rosie,
do you see this World Cup
being something that's
going to enjoy
participation as a success,
or is the main success going
to be more of an increased
viewership, just a
larger fan base, people
being more aware of rugby
amongst the other big sports
in the US.
I'd be interested
to hear that, too.
ROSS YOUNG: Rosie,
do you want to start?
ROSIE SPAULDING:
Sure, no, absolutely.
I mean, a huge part of our--
probably our number
one objective
for running this tournament
was to increase participation
and awareness of the game.
So it's about-- been
growing participation,
but part of growing
participation is growing
awareness with an
emerging sport like that--
like this.
So we've been-- there's a lot
of focus on that education piece
that I talked about,
and just really growing
the awareness of the game,
both here in the Bay Area,
but also nationally.
And through that-- and on the
participation side specifically
we've been very much Bay
Area-focused, and leveraging
the tournament to introduce
schools to the game, et cetera.
But I mean, absolutely,
it's your number one
priority for us, and
with any major event,
you have that
opportunity to leverage
the tournament for
different reasons,
and that's a major
one for us, and it's
sort of a micro version of
what the '94 soccer World
Cup did for soccer, on a
smaller scale, but still just a
important.
So what can we do with this
opportunity to grow the game?
ROSS YOUNG: And to come
back to the balance of club
versus this college, I mean,
it has to be a balancing act.
I keep on saying
that, but it has.
I mean, it's no good,
nothing, certain people
try-- you can't
just replicate how
it works in other
parts of the world
and try and force it
into this environment.
And you look at the lessons
that soccer learned.
You've got the
advantages, especially
with Title IX and [INAUDIBLE]
soccer awareness, a lot of it
was driven by the
women really getting
involved in full
NCAA varsity programs
off the back of funding
through Title IX.
We've got to pick up
and try and use that.
I mean Cal--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Ross,
can you just explain
what Title IX is for folks.
ROSS YOUNG: So Title IX's
all about equalization
of funding across men
and women, across sport
expenditure within that
particular college network.
So you've got huge programs
spending lots of money
on football programs, there
has to be a balance there,
and soccer did a great
job in harnessing that,
and rugby have got to
do that more as well.
I mean, Cal's one of the few
that's full varsity men-wise.
I think there's only about
nine, isn't there, varsities.
There's about 20-odd women's
that are now NCAA varsity.
40 is the magic
number for it to be--
to move from being
a club sport to be
full NCAA-ratified tournament.
And the women are
obviously a lot closer
to doing that than the men are.
There are also incredible
associations-- the National
Small Colleges
Rugby Association,
they've got 220-odd men's
side, 115 women's side playing
in national contests every year.
And again, the small colleges,
a lot of the good rugby players
that come through that
play with the Eagles
come from those
smaller colleges,
because they tend to be
the prime focus of sport
within those smaller
environments.
So there's certainly
lots out there,
but it has to be
a balancing act,
and we've got to hopefully--
drive participation is key.
AUDIENCE: So to the
uninitiated, sevens--
where did it come from?
Why does it exist, and what
is the relationship to 15s,
I guess, would be the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BLAINE SCULLY: 15s is
the traditional game,
and then I believe sevens
was invented in Scotland--
ROSIE SPAULDING: That's right.
BLAINE SCULLY: --in Melrose.
ROSIE SPAULDING: Melrose.
ROSS YOUNG: In Melrose, yeah.
And it's very much--
I think sevens initially
came to pass with--
and again, we talk about values
of rugby, community values.
So sevens really started as
a end-of-season celebration
where lots of the local clubs
would get together and play
a tournament over a
day, with the barbecue
and beers, et cetera.
So that's really how
it started, and then
as it's developed into
a sport of its own,
it's now very-- as Blaine
mentioned-- very specific
athlete requirements.
But yeah, initially
in those days
it was a social,
end-of-season gathering,
was how it really kicked off.
Sevens have been around for--
I mean, 1866 is the original--
BLAINE SCULLY: 120
years or something.
ROSS YOUNG: --rugby.
And I think sevens
pretty much is
when you don't
have enough people,
people would play
the form of sevens.
So it's been around from
the very early stages,
but it's only really
the last 20 years
where it's been established
as a standalone sport.
ROSIE SPAULDING: Yeah,
I was just going to add,
I think that it has
great potential,
especially with we're seeing
the Millennials as being
on of our major demographics,
and it is this very fast-paced,
quick, 15-minute--
audience has a 15-minute
attention span for a game.
And a lot of its
appeal is that it
is easier to understand than
the 90-minute game, fast,
and quick to learn, and great
to watch from an entertainment
perspective as well.
So I think that's one of
the reasons we're starting
to see growth in in every year.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: And
other than rugby,
are their other sports that you
like to play, watch, or enjoy?
BLAINE SCULLY: Everything.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Everything.
Multi-sport?
BLAINE SCULLY:
Yeah, multi-sport.
I mean, I think when you're
an athlete you just kind
of appreciate athletic
excellence wherever you see it,
and performance excellence.
And I enjoyed watching
Wimbledon this weekend, or golf,
and obviously I'm a 49ers
fan and Giants fan--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: I'm sorry.
BLAINE SCULLY: --because
I'm from Sacramento.
[LAUGHTER]
BLAINE SCULLY: It's all right.
We're OK.
We will be.
And yeah, so I think as an
athlete I just appreciate
the greats, and the
LeBrons, and Tom Bradys,
and all those guys who exhibit
athletic excellence, I think,
is really cool.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: That's great.
ROSIE SPAULDING: Yeah,
similar for watching sport.
I love watching sport at the
highest standard, whatever
that might be, whether it's
soccer World Cup or Olympics.
But I would always rather
participate in sport
than watch it, if I
get the opportunity.
BLAINE SCULLY: I would agree.
ROSIE SPAULDING: And
that's skiing, or surfing,
or mountain biking,
whatever it might be, just--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Doing it.
ROSIE SPAULDING: --doing it is
always my preference if I can.
ROSS YOUNG: I used
to root for Seattle.
I was much more an armchair fan.
[LAUGHTER]
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: Nothing
wrong with that.
ROSS YOUNG: I think
it's the same thing,
that you get drawn to sport,
and I'm very much like Blaine.
You know, if it's--
not so much now, I'm
old and decrepit,
but getting out there, doing
it, but just any sport is--
I used to play a little
bit of basketball
because I was, again, coming
back to my athletic prowess,
was the worst trainer ever.
And to try basketball, probably
played in the summer in the UK.
So at least it kept me
moving, and I didn't
have to start pre-season.
It used to take me
three months to get fit,
and a month to get unfit.
So keep doing something so--
yeah, basketball definitely, and
then rugby through and through.
BLAINE SCULLY:
Sorry, just to jump
in, I think that's a
real appeal about rugby,
is that it combines a lot of
these different elements of all
these different games, and
throws it into one competition.
And that's what I
found in my experience,
and that's one of the reasons
why I love it so much is
you have to play offense,
and you have to play defense,
and you have to
be able to catch,
and you have to be able to
pass, and you have to do all
these different things
inside one game,
and that's what
makes it special,
I think-- in addition
to all the values
and the different elements.
How much sports talk about
integrity, and sportsmanship,
and discipline as values?
And then safety--
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: They
call the referee, sir.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BLAINE SCULLY: Make
sure you do that.
ROSS YOUNG: The rugby values--
the respect, the camaraderie,
and I think there are so many
crossovers to your working life
as well.
And I think that is--
there's great examples of people
that get involved in rugby,
and the benefits of
that decision-making,
a little bit of confidence.
And Play Rugby USA
is a great program
that really hits some lower
demographics, initially
out in New York and now in
LA, with kids who would never
had a chance to get
to college that have
got to college through rugby.
So I think the--
and then if you Google Olive
Kilifi from the Seattle
Seahawks--
Seawolves, even.
I mean, he-- at the end of--
when they won an overall
MLR championship,
he did a great interview
about exactly that, and about
the difference that rugby made
to him, not just as a player
but from his own personal
life, by taking on those values
and adapting them to what
you do off the field as well.
FLEUR KNOWSLEY: So everyone just
join me in thanking our guests,
and good luck for the
recovery, and the tournament
this weekend.
[APPLAUSE]